Charlie it's Oh Charlie yes so Charlie
is so cool
hello youtube today I'm gonna tell you
how you get beat shield
now many people will tell you that there
isn't any way to get featured and
they're probably right but I want to
give you an idea about how you might be
able to possibly get featured these are
some little tips little ideas and just
general mess of the stuff that could
help you get well on your way to
becoming the next YouTube celebrity I
just had way too many kind gestures
first I'm going to lay down some ground
rules these are things that you have to
follow otherwise there's no way of you
getting heated at all ever
it's just nothing okay first things
first get rid of copyrighted stuff okay
that means no music and no logos of any
kind okay basically the thing is with
YouTube they're not going to want any
copyright stuff going on their homepage
cuz if they see anything like that
they're gonna be all like I don't know
you need to reuse that I know it's bit
oh I can't I can't use that we don't we
don't want to get sued do you guys know
obviously not everybody who works at
YouTube is gay I just wanted to do that
kind of accent thing okay so that's the
ground rule okay I know they said we're
there we were gonna have ground rules
but whatever
here we go now I'm gonna give you some
ideas ideas ideas ideas about how you
can make excellent videos number one rap
about something if you want if you've
got a point to put cross or you want to
say something it usually works better if
you rap my name's mr. C and I'm here to
say if you want to get featured this is
the only way you got to watch my video
got to do what I do and if you don't you
can do a poo but if if you have time to
bother writing it down because that was
all improvised if you have time to write
a rap down and do it it usually works
better than just talking randomly into
the camera number two it's a good idea
and not to have many subscribers to your
videos youtube prefer people who are
kind of you know people who not many
other people know about you know you
know like somebody like me someone who
hasn't got a hundred subscribers yet
someone
not as well-known because they like
people that aren't as well known it's
just it's just nicer just nicer number
three no eighteen nurse well obviously
you can't do poor in any way but if
you've got like lots of abusive swearing
and stuff
and you know if your video has to
be rated as an 18 if you can't watch it
unless you're 18 then um YouTube I'm
gonna want it the feature that cuz it's
naughty number four is another idea
arty-farty stuff that's what I got
written down arty-farty stuff
everybody knows people like electric
Asylum of Arts and it's it's a great
thing to do because it's just so cool
it's so cool to watch and if you got the
talent you should definitely use it
because it's so great to see those kind
of videos and YouTube love them a little
of them there we go number five plan it
out you might have seen me waving around
this pen because I have a plan how to
get future on youtube if you run
rambling on and doing you know nothing
no point to your watch it and you write
like like you don't really what you're
saying and you exactly like that don't
do that you're gonna have a plan it's
what you're doing
it works okay number six cute
if you can use something cute like a
little kitten or bunny rabbit or you
know picture of me that you've drawn
something really cute and lovely there
that's something that YouTube likes as
well because it's so people will people
love those kind of videos so so sweet
little kitty oh oh it's fallen over oh
it's so sweet
it's me people like it I can't think why
number seven this is another rule no
video responses video responses aren't a
good idea okay just just don't make your
own video make it something good make
your own good video not something about
somebody else's good video okay that's
that's not don't know do it number eight
be relevant to right now right now be
relevant
Paris Hilton going to jail Paris Hilton
went to jail everyone huh I I don't give
a but yeah but she went to jail she
went to jail
Oh Paris Hilton went to jail if you can
be bothered to talk about something like
that something relevant or stuff people
are gonna search for videos on it
Paris Paris Hilton Oh video about Paris
Hilton people are gonna want to you know
look for it because it's relevant to
right now and that's a good thing a good
good wait yeah
number nine dare to do something mad
slash break a bone or something if you
do something crazy people are gonna love
it
people gonna want to see that keep jump
on building or anything like that
people people are gonna go mad they're
gonna like that so do something crazy do
something daring do something dangerous
number ten make a video and which nobody
is going to like you complain about the
world complain about everyone complain
about something everybody else really
likes you know like like me or something
like that something really you know
great I'm sorry I'm really arrogant I've
used myself as an example twice now
let's try not to do that do that again
shall we
number twelve I spoke about rapping at
the beginning of this video just as well
as rapping just making it into a song
works just as well fine I'll get out my
guitar
this is video about how to get featured
on YouTube
this is video this is video about what
you need to know my guitars not a tune
anymore it's not usually a good idea to
take someone else's tune and then add
your own own lyrics some people do that
but no make you meet your own song it's
more it's more it's more cool number
thirteen hilariousness this is one of
the most important things you can
possibly do really it's one of the most
important things be funny okay be funny
if you can be funny then you got it
sorted I mean so many people are doing
it it's the list of this that's thing to
do
I mean even if you're talking about
something really serious like how to get
featured on YouTube you still need to be
funny you know this is a really generic
one but this is also one of the most
important things make a cool video I
mean this is just like so broad but if
it's something that people can look at
and go wow
that's really cool that's really cool
people love it it will work something
cool and this is really the most
important thing yeah so Google ones
before were you know really important
things but this is the most important
thing that you can possibly do this is
one of the best ideas that you can do to
get featured on YouTube make a video
about how to get featured on YouTube I
don't know if this actually if that idea
actually works yet but I'm sure we'll
find out probably won't
I'm so silly I'm so silly
but fun and I'll see you next time get
you next night